SHIELD AND SAYS IT IS THEOAL AND
THAT TIME IN THE GLOVE OF DEMKO.
SHARP ANGLED POST!
OH, WHAT AO, CENTERING.
ALL THE WAY ACROSS WITH RIELLY
NOW TAKING THAT PUCK IN THE
OFFICIAL AND YOU ARE RIGHT.
HE HAD NOBRAD MARCHAND IS THEREG
FOR A REBOUND.>> Announcer: JAC,
CASINO GAMES, PERFECTLY MADE FOR
BRUINS, THEY ARE 0-1.
THE CANUCKS HAD ONENEOFFSIDE AT.
>> John S.: THEY ARE HAVING A
LOOK IN TORONTO AND
>> John S.: J.T. MILLER AGAINST
CURT
THIS SEASON AND McAVOY WITH CIRS
WRISTED IN FRONT AND TIPPED IN,
E
JUST FEATHERS THIS ONE AND LOOK
WITH SEVEN ASSISTS IN HIS LAST
THE HANDLE AND THE BRUINS TO THE
POWER PLAY BUT DID NOT
McAVOY.
MARCHAND, LETS IT GO.
AND EARLIER,
THE TIP-IN, THATCHET
WAS THEIR UNDOING AND HERE NOW
FOR 40 SECONDS FIVE-ON-THREE FOR
THE BRUIN
SCHENN, HE HAS TON THE
THIRD PERIOD WITH McAVOY NOW
TAKING THAT NOW.
STILL HAS IT.
AND IT IS POOLMAN WITH
IS CHARLIE McAVOY, WALKING
PAST BOESER, GAINING CENTRE,
IT.
GETS THE WHISTLE.
ENDS AS WE ARE SET NOW TO GOILL
CHANGE THEIR FORWARDS WITH
HUGHES NOW CARRYING THE
>> John G.: AND PEARSON, A GOOD
PLAY THERE ON HAULA,HERE TO HAL,
THAT PUCK TO MILLER,ERS ARE PERS
YEAR, HEE LOST THE HANDLE THERE,
TRYING TO MAKE A MOVE.
AND THE
YEAR FOR
MISSED THE NET AND
THATCHER DEMKO MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN
A PIECE OF IT.
BOTH TEAMS,N
HOME ICE IN HIS THREE NHL
>> John S.: PATIENCE
PERSONIFIE CAREER AGAINST
THATCHER DEMKO NOW STOPPING SIX
OF EIGHT THIS SEASON WITH HISMK!
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and ApplauseIR NEW C.
HORVAT,